[Music]
hi my name is Susie Wallace I want to
solve the unsolvable I want to bring
resolution to the most haunting
Mysteries why are you smiling just my
natural expression
what is it selfie
when I solve this case and become a big
hero I can't wait
it doesn't matter if you have five
suspects or 500 more often than you
think the culprit is right under your
nose
I'm Susie
Susie Ohio's own Nancy Drew
take us through your investigation
I remember learning about heroes in
school but I never thought I'd be
sitting next to one
cat Charles
did you get told I just got chills
everybody else in the world they wear
masks not with you Susie never change
okay
I was wrong about you even though you
saved the day you still have no social
life
I promise I'm not going to tell anybody
what I found I have no idea what you're
talking about Jesse was wearing this
half a day disappeared you can tell me
what happened
[Music]
life takes unexpected twists
you're following me they found more DNA
evidence really
you can be the best criminal in the
world but you cannot outrun science
a new tragedy has struck even the most
perfect plans don't always work out
you're my prime suspect my guys
following you for weeks
but eventually a solution will present
itself